les crimes alors justement ses revenus
vous êtes dans la chirurgie esthétique
et sur ces femmes qui après une
grossesse bah oui c'est compliqué avait
eu pitié c'est pour faire des efforts
avec surtout alors moi je dis pas ce que
j'ai vécu ça y est pas très longtemps
surtout prenez votre temps c'est pas
grave on n'est pas toutes logées à la
même enseigne
ça rend les choses difficiles ma mère
nature se penchent sur le berceau de
certaines et elle elle passe totalement
à côté verso de d'autres il y en a qui
sort de l'accouchement comme kim
kardashian et d'autres comme moi c'est
magnifique
kim kardashian à l'été elle était elle
était elle avait pris beaucoup mais
après direct après l'accouchement elle
pas alors fait qu'elle a vu cette
méthode il ya une méthode qui permet
donc vous vous accouchez vous accouchez
star américaine
regardez cgt différents biba part pour
la france où elle va subir un mot mime
et cover
bonjour
cinéma en seulement quatre heures il va
pratiquer une liposuccion des cuisses
une abdominoplastie et une réduction
mammaire les jeunes mamans peuvent
passer d'une taille 44 à une taille 38
ans 24 heures pour le vendre c'est
autour de 5000 euros
un petit peu moins pour les ce1 4000 on
est autour de 12000 euros et aucune
prise en charge par la sécurité sociale
c'est le prix à payer pour une opération
encadrée en france
trois jours plus tard et après tu ouvres
les yeux
si vous êtes ému on a avec les nexans je
n'arrive pas croit que ces mois là on
obtient souhait alors oui ça n'a pas de
prix
alors moi écoutez-moi pas voir son
sourire quand je vois comment avait
compté je ne sois très choqué ce
jugement alors annoncé trois grossesses
en quatre ans donc autant vous dire que
j'ai accumulée et un moment donné je me
suis jamais sentie obligée d'y aller
parce que par le corps il se transforme
majoritaire c'est une transformation et
c'est une vraie souffrance qu'ont
certaines femmes en moi je le dis il
faut il faut que la chirurgie justement
il faut que les femmes c'est si ça peut
aider une femme et bien tant mieux ça
aide et si elles peuvent aussi le faire
d'elle même on sait bien aussi mais bon
après l'aller
si ça peut ramener femme heureuse c'est
très bien de toute manière et chirurgie
n'est pas la seule alternative
il ya un peu
la tension sur le téléspectateur quand
même de dire que c'est le cas c'est très
douloureux c'est une opération il ya un
mois pour s'en remettre
c est aux portes et une gaine pendant un
mois et ça les maires beaucoup de
globules on perd toutes nos forces
enfin on perd toute notre énergie
pendant que vous avez été touchés le
spécialiste de ludivine qui l'a fait
votre femme nous en est témoin parce
qu'elle était la journée l'enfant dans
tout juste une chose elle ma perf et
surtout géant et un médecin qui m'en a
parlé de ces opérations il dise quand
même que c'est très bien de faire
surtout quand on se sent pas bien il n'y
a aucune honte à le faire en revanche
avant de se repérer vient à penser comme
à faire un petit résumé la grèce est
compact et oui les plus spécifiques
s'adresse vite voilà est plein et la
graisse du ventre mois les résultats
sont efficaces je vous dis ça je ne
voulais rien